(VOICEOVER)- The
riverbed is bone dry.
But the trees are still alive.
So that means that there's
still water here somewhere.
And if you pay enough
attention, the desert
will show you where to look.
I'm just looking at
these four-leaf ferns here.
There's more green at this plant
than I've seen anywhere else.
So might be promising.
(VOICEOVER)- This
vegetation could be
the X on a hidden treasure map.
I know that this plant
needs a lot of water.
So for it to be alive,
there has to be a water
source just below the surface.
Yeah.
There must be some
sort of spring,
because I know that the
water table in this river's
got to be lower than this.
Yeah.
That is wet mud, for sure.
Oh, yeah.
It's in there.
Look at that.
Water.
Oh, this is good.
This is good.
And it's really cold.
This is coming from
somewhere deep underground.
(VOICEOVER)- Large sand grains
like these hold nearly twice
as much water as fine sand.
It's an incredible find.
And it'll keep me out of
danger for a few more hours.
It's getting really
easy to dig now.
Oh, yeah.
There's water.
Yup.
Nice.
Muddy water, but it's water.
I'll wet this cloth.
(VOICEOVER)- Since this spring
comes from deep underground,
it's not likely to be
contaminated by animal waste
or flying insects
carrying diseases, making
it my best option for drinking.
It's gritty water.
But this is great.
I am really happy
with what I got.
(VOICEOVER)- I may not
find any more water today.
So I need to make
the most of this.
Basically, I'm held
hostage to this waterhole
until I get my fill of water
as much as I can drink,
because I don't know if I'll be
this lucky as I keep moving on.